[Music]
expecto patronum
[Music]
[Music]
one of the most iconic moments in the
harry potter story has to be when he
finally masters an extremely difficult
spell called the expecto patronum this
is one of the most powerful magic tricks
that a wizard can make and in the
subsequent movies we see harry and his
friends use it to protect themselves
against the dementors and if you love
learning english with your favorite
movies like harry potter then be sure to
hit that subscribe button and the bell
down below
because every week we help you to
understand fast native speech without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles
so you definitely do not want to miss a
single new lesson
are you sure about this harry you know
this is very advanced magic well beyond
the ordinary wizarding level i'm
close your sure
[Music]
concentrate
shall we
wand is it ready
here we go come on sit up deep breaths
it's all right
i didn't expect you to do it the first
time
that would have been remarkable here
eat this you'll feel better
that's one nasty dementor oh no no no no
no
that was a boggart harry a boggart the
real thing would be worse much much
worse
[Music]
now that was harry's first attempt to
cast the spectropatronum charm
let's learn these two words because
they're key vocabulary from the
wizarding world of harry potter cast can
be used as a verb you cast a spell or
charm a spell is a piece of magic that
someone does or the special words or
ceremonies used in doing it
there's nothing in here about using
defensive spells using spells
i can't imagine why you would need to
use spells in my classroom
a charm is similar to a spell in this
case it is a phrase or action believed
to have special magical powers
cast your charms to disarm your opponent
only to disarm
now are you sure about this harry you
know this is very advanced magic well
beyond the ordinary wizarding level i'm
sure
in this case beyond means more or
greater he's saying that the expecto
patronum charm is beyond his current
level of ability we can emphasize this
adjective with well or with far or even
way as in this clip magic way beyond the
talents of a fourth year
by the way a wizard is what you can
describe harry or ron as as for hermione
you'd call her a witch because this is
the female word for wizard in the harry
potter movies they use this word wizard
in other ways like here when he says
that the expected patronum charm is
beyond the ordinary wizarding level or
in this clip when he says wizard kind to
refer to all wizards as a group
it is my job to arm you against the
foulest creatures known to wizard kind
we also often hear hogwarts referred to
as the school for witchcraft and
wizardry these both mean the practice of
magic in the harry potter world we would
probably say that hermione practices
witchcraft and harry practices wizardry
concentrate
shall we
shall we is a question that you can use
to suggest that something should be done
especially something you're expected to
do it's like saying are we ready to do
what we are here to do it's also used
after a suggestion
shall we oh yeah
we don't want to be late
wand is already
a wand is this instrument that wizards
and witches wave around when they need
to use their magic lupin says at the
ready meaning prepared or available for
immediate use example the cowboy walked
with his gun at the ready
deep breaths
all right
a breath is the action of taking air
into your lungs
note it's pronounced breath
when it's a verb it's breathe and it's
spelled like
this come on breathe
a deep breath is the action of taking
more air into your lungs we say take a
deep breath
let's now take a look at the connected
speech used in this clip i didn't expect
you to do it the first time
that would have been remarkable
generally native english speakers like
to save energy when they speak that's
why instead of saying that would have
been he says that would have been would
have becomes woulda isn't it easier to
say it like that
let's take a quiz in which of these
clips do they say would have with
connected speech
if snape's cloak hadn't caught fire and
broken my eye contact i would have
succeeded
i dirty great snakes someone would have
seen it
i would have considered a degree
personal triumph
i would have succeeded i dirty great
snakes someone would have seen it i
would have considered it a great
personal triumph
[Music]
i would have considered a degree
personal triumph
i didn't expect you to do it the first
time that would have been remarkable
remarkable is a formal alternative to
very good
remarkable feat don't you think
to enter hogwarts castle on one's own
completely undetected quite remarkable
yeah
that's one nasty dementor here he
describes the dementor as nasty as used
here this word means horrendous and
frightening also notice how he uses the
word one for emphasis
you might say that was one incredible
experience
by the way do you ever feel lost when we
natives speak fast like this it's
frustrating isn't it we cut some words
we connect others some sounds even morph
or they disappear altogether it's
nothing like you were taught in school
but guess what it is possible for you to
confidently understand natives no matter
how fast we speak and this is exactly
why in our fluent with friends course we
take you outside of the classroom and
help you to learn english as it is
really spoken and have a ton of fun
doing it with friends which various
academic studies show is the best tv
series out there for learning english
can you imagine being able to understand
english as effortlessly as you
understand your native language well you
can and guess what
you can even try it absolutely free with
our three part master class so learn
more and sign up by clicking up here or
down in the description below now
[Music]
as a matter of interest what were you
thinking which memory did you choose
the first time i rode a broom
well that's not good enough not nearly
good enough
there's another
it's not
happy exactly
well it is
it's the happiest i've ever felt
but it's complicated
is it strong
then let's give it a try
you feel ready
just do it
expectonum
[Music]
well done harry
well done
i think i've had enough
for today yes sit down here eat this it
helps it really helps
and just so you know harry i think you
would have given your father a run for
his money and that
he's saying something
i was thinking of him
and mum
seeing their faces
they were talking to me
just talking
that's the memory i chose
i don't even know if it's real
but it's the best i have
[Music]
as a matter of interest what were you
thinking which memory did you choose the
first time i rode a broom
road is the past tense of ride you ride
a horse a bike or if you're like harry a
broom
that's not good enough not nearly good
enough
not nearly as an expression we used to
mean much less than or much less than
expected we usually use it to make
comparisons example my pieces are not
nearly as good as yours
let's give it a try
you feel ready there's some connected
speech in this utterance as well
repeat after me then let's give it a try
then let's give it a try
can you identify where there's linking
most times you'll hear give it a try not
give it a try
also the t in it becomes a soft d sound
as it is between vowel sounds we call
this the american t
i think i've had enough
for today yes sit down here
we say i've had enough when we want to
say that we don't want to do something
anymore whether because we're tired or
perhaps angry if you go for a run and
you get very tired after having run for
an hour you could say i've had enough
for today if you're very disappointed
with your girlfriend or boyfriend and
want to break up you might tell them
i've had enough of you another context
we use this expression in is when we've
had enough to eat meaning we're full
you'd say i've had enough you may want
to add a thank you to make sure you
don't sound rude
hey what is your favorite scene from
harry potter let me know down in the
comments below and we might just make a
lesson with it oh yeah
and just so you know harry
i think you would have given your father
a run for his money and that
he's saying something
we use just so you know to give some
information to someone we think might
need it or they might want to know about
something example
just you know it's going to rain so you
might want to take an umbrella
then he uses this interesting idiom to
give someone a run for their money this
means to be as good at something as
someone who is extremely good his father
was known to be a masterful wizard if
you say something like i wasn't
expecting they would give barcelona a
run for their money you're expressing
surprise that a minor team even though
they didn't win gave barcelona a
challenge
[Music]
are you sure about this harry you know
this is very advanced magic well beyond
the ordinary wizarding level i'm sure
what's the female form for wizard
which
close your eyes concentrate
[Music]
shall we
wand is already
here we go come on sit up
can you remember how this word is
pronounced harry here has used a lot of
energy and now he needs to take a deep
breath
deep breaths
all right
i didn't expect you to do it the first
time
that would have been remarkable here
eat this you'll feel better
that's one nasty dementor oh no no no no
no
that was a bugger harry a boggart
the real thing would be worse much much
worse
as a matter of interest what were you
thinking which memory did you choose
the first time i rode a broom
well that's not good enough not nearly
good enough
there's another
it's not
happy exactly
well it is
it's the happiest i've ever felt
but it's complicated
is it strong
then let's give it a try
you feel ready
just do it
expecton
[Music]
well done harry
well done
i think i've had enough
for today yes sit down here eat this it
helps it really helps
and just so you know harry
i think you would have given your father
a run for his money and that
is saying something if you give someone
a run for their money you do something
very badly just as well as them
relatively well
[Music]
oh
i was thinking of him
and mum
seeing their faces
they were talking to me
just talking
that's the memory i chose
i don't even know if it's real
but it's the best i have
do you love harry potter then don't miss
this lesson where you can learn about
the rules of the magical game of
quidditch in english let's watch a clip
from that now
[Music]
[Applause]
ah yeah today you will learn english
with harry potter and the magical sport
of the wizarding world quidditch